scp-2305-a an anomalous document that  manifests methods of neutralizing  various scps all of which are doomed to  fail so what did it have to say about  scp-682  to make a very long and elaborate story  short through a mix of anomalies and  massive hydrogen bombs  scp-682 would be transported to the moon  and blown to smithereens in a massive  ridiculous explosion earth is pounded by  the resulting meteors from the explosion  while only a tiny quantity of 682's  blood survived the bombardment it  managed to regenerate and adapt it  became the size of saturn and ended up  eating our solar system the moral of the  story don't redacted with this gecko